previously on TV sins yeah where am i we
accidentally replaced your heart with a
baked potato you have about three
seconds to live
[Music]
excitement also I'm loving this streak
too it intro with zero commentary on
what's going on but are we skipping over
this incredibly brief visual of amethyst
I had to pause with surgical precision
to see this deadly cuddle pole also also
does amethyst regularly wake up out of a
dead sleep pull down her shirt sugar
chest gym and say her name's at kinky
I think it's kinky and this is a kid
show Steven obviously went to the Cookie
Monster school of eating things man I'll
never understand how it's so hard to get
food into your mouth
potato chips are brought to you by that
weird old Nancy comic strip you used to
read to your grandmother or after the
glaucoma I got so bad she had to start
smoking six ounces of weed per day but
too dark a comic was weird man another
thing to say in a pilot episode since
we've never been introduced to any of
these characters prior to this oh look a
fashionable belly bag back in my day
these were fanny packs em this is a sim
for dumb fashion choices
I understand budgetary constraints but
there wasn't enough to give Steven
normal-looking teeth looks like he has
two pieces of mozzarella string cheese
in his mouth what is garnet doing back
there does she also have x-ray vision
because seeing clearly out of stained
glass is really hard you look like a
clown is up with these two gems here
just seconds ago they were encouraging
this poor bastard but now they've
suddenly turned into bullies straight
out of the other Steven universe
none of this home looks structurally
sound support trees are resting on Rock
the stairs aren't attached to braces and
the plumbing is very concerning dude if
there are any cracks about this kids
weight I will not be having them
considering they live ten feet away from
a donut shop and that has set him up for
failure
what thing blatant their responsibility
on the part of your gem sister that
thing what are they anyway which is or
ghosts or something I'm all for being an
[ __ ] but let's have standards and use
the special donut tissue when handling
the goods the monster also considering
Steven simply said just give me three
donuts
how did Lars know what kind of a gap
form aren't they oh like hot girls
you're not exactly
girls Steven that's racist this
time-travel device is so goddamn
convenient that I'm convinced Tony Stark
invented it overnight Steven garnet was
defending Steven to the crystal gems you
look like a clown don't make fun of
Steven and three minutes later she's
calling him a buttface
am i supposed to be liking these people
the righteous gemstones oh no there's
something something monster thingy is
gonna do some evil division and the
stakes are super high because of a
device literally known as the thing look
the show may be awesome but it sure
didn't get off to the most auspicious
start in terms of plot development oh
the butt face comment was a plot device
so that Steven can do something
interesting in a battle so rather than
depend on character congruity we're okay
with garnet being a [ __ ] to her buddy
and needing to have a snarky comeback in
order to defeat the evil skull and save
the world did I get that insane sure
seems like it's now content to hang back
and not do anything while you're
hatching this plant maybe just wait the
[ __ ] out it's okay Steven what
the what I know we're in Fantasyland
here but they've been extremely
concerned with that ancient artifact and
now that it's destroyed they're just
like whatevs to the pilot oh god this is
so sugary sounding my teeth hurt and my
soul is trying to rip free from my body
and high to the dark shadows of my
YouTube awards what a terrible place for
a population to develop when the tide
rises over the barriers everyone's gonna
be swimming for their lives
No some of the spending way too much
time putting cupcakes into cookie jars
they're obviously very good at it
because none of the frosting is
disturbed but what a serious waste of
time also if I buy a cupcake do I get
the cookie jar dude am I supposed to
carefully reach in and pull out the
cupcake without disturbing the icing I
can't do that
I'm sorry Steven I guess they stopped
making them stop making them
Sadie takes time out of her busy work
schedule to play a good old-fashioned
roundup the pronoun game in this
universe pop is called soda and this
reignites one of my least favorite
debates soda pop coke who cares
drink water shut the [ __ ] up awesome
what is the donut raging about does he
hate rectangles the shapes enrage him
will he be able to reconcile his own
emotional turmoil as he stares into the
mirror every day realizing he is a shape
and there's no escaping this reality
lion lickers nobody likes them they
don't even look like lions Steven would
be universally great TV sins also what
is this crab juice sort of sick uterus
happily endorses liquid crustaceans also
also the sign on the wall who's Joe
isn't Joe coffee
it's beverages clearly soda there popper
I'm back at the Samantha queer mole
again it's that time device thingy Wow
if you miss your wimpy ice cream so much
why don't you make some with your magic
belly button I'm not one to make fun of
style choices but I will make fun of
someone who is making fun of style
choices especially when they choose to
elongate and put larger holes in their
earlobes to code for this war if the
freezer is cold enough for Stephen to
draw on it should not have an impression
of his lips now to all that matters is
that Steven is happy this is how kids
become spoiled there's a more obvious
monkey appeasement two stoners watching
this on Cartoon Network at 4:20 in the
afternoon I have yet to see it breathe
don't force it yeah and try not to poop
yourself either things said during
childbirth and threesomes where am I
need to summon my weapon and just happen
[Music]
I don't know what all these vignettes
are supposed to mean to the bigger
picture but I do know the picture of my
pants just got bigger again clearly
amethyst is an [ __ ] is destroyed
their property many times so wouldn't
Lorenz immediately look at amethyst and
call her out for her shenanigans or at
the very least demand she replaces the
trash can awesome earlier we saw the
store shelves stocked with holy cake and
fried dough but clearly they are selling
their inventory and having to throw away
massive amounts of food this is not okay
make less food or give it away for
safety so I'm supposed to work really
hard and not try it all at the same time
article 3 line 7 and the cinemasins
employee handbook somehow makes its way
into this episode obviously between the
pilot in the first episode there were
some creative changes but in this case
garnet summoning her weapon got a
serious downgrade when they removed the
sweet circlets scream or you're just
lactose intolerant but that would
probably be a different weapon and it
would definitely be shooting out of the
opposite end also glad we're having a
show out there for kids we're eating ice
cream is what makes you stronger pop I
wasn't great but at least it promoted
eating ones vegetables maybe summoning
your own weapons would be a good thing
to do right now you know instead of
thinking about the kids field that he
clearly hasn't been able to control
since the show started and for some time
now maybe less talking and more of that
saving stuff you know I'm just realizing
that their house is nestled into the
statue in one whole space and I'm all
for that
[Music]
damn for such a short show these scenes
seem to go on forever don't worry Steven
I'm sure someday you'll figure out how
to activate your chin uh does he need to
he's done heroic superhero level feats
without having his gem activated he
leaps off buildings with no injury he
can outrun massive monsters and he is
strong enough to swing a small freezer
with laser lasso accuracy maybe remind
him of those abilities when you're
comforting his fragile ego you know
that's breast milk we are the crystal
gems
you look like a clown I'm funny how I
mean funny like I'm a clown may amuse
you
well if it isn't Steven aren't they all
like hot girls
you're not exactly a hot girl Steven
well the jerk star called they're
running out of you oh I should have said
that that's really funny they don't even
look like lions we should probably call
the damn exterminator
James weapons
[Music]
all right I finally beat Gary I'm sick I
need too many cookie cats ha ha ha ha
yeah